In seventh grade I looked through a
microscope for the first time and I saw
a Paramecium swimming around and I was
just fascinated I never wanted to move
from a microscope again that was where I
wanted to spend my life I'm Jo
Handelsman I'm a microbiologist it was
just like that look huh how does that
fit together and it was clearly girl
science girls can't do that when you ask
kids to draw scientists most will draw
the same image white bald guy with a
pointy beard little glasses and a white
lab coat and then when I was in 10th
grade I had a biology teacher mr. post
Leone and he convinced me that I could
do science as a girl and finally when I
got to graduate school I started seeing
role models in science women who had
done what I wanted to do they'd become
biologists professors they did research
and realized those two things can go
together you can be female and you can
be a science professor you don't have to
look like those guys
microbiome is a community of
microorganisms associated with some
environment from the ocean to the soil
to the human gut and it's rapidly
evolving science we are beginning to
understand the roles that they play in
regulating our own health and our immune
systems much of chronic disease is now
being associated with changes in our
microbiomes obesity heart disease asthma
the list is very extensive if we can
control those microbial communities we
can take enormous advantage of them I
was one of the science advisors for
President Obama during the last three
years of his administration welcome to
the White House Science Fair he is a
wonderful fan of science this stuff's
really cool it was the high point of his
day having a discussion about
initiatives to change American science
precision medicine is a science trying
to figure out what's different between
individual people that makes one person
respond to a treatment and another
person not
President Obama was personally committed
to it tonight I'm launching a new
precision medicine initiative he was
very excited about making this front and
center of the future of American
medicine the right treatment at the
right time a bill was passed that had
about four point eight billion dollars
would you do this I think it's one of
our most successful initiatives from my
time at the White House
I was in the habit of giving President
Obama stuff microbes and these were
little miniature microorganisms that
represented in real microbes the very
first one I gave him was of a
streptococcus flesh-eating bacteria one
of the scientists was just totally
baffled what are you gonna do with it
little coy it was quite an experience to
work with him at one of the world's
problems was that antibiotics that we
have no longer worked with many of our
diseases but industry has kind of lost
interest we're trying to rebuild that
interest soil bacteria are these
prolific producers of antibiotic
activity about 75% of the antibiotics in
current use are from soil bacteria
and there's some pretty good evidence
that bacteria are producing antibiotics
for sending messages to each other and
so we are just co-opting something that
the bacteria are making to use as drugs
for our own purposes
small world is something that I started
in 2012 to teach science through solving
the worlds of problems with young bright
scientists in the classroom they would
learn about science through culturing
bacteria from soil for production of
antibiotics it's been a really
extraordinary process to see all of the
students and their instructors
passionate about antibiotic discovery
from soil
above all failure is okay there are
messages that are sent in science about
failure that just shouldn't be sent
failure is a part of science it doesn't
mean you're not good at it it doesn't
mean to stop it just means to go back
and do it again I so often hear students
say oh I'm not a science person I always
thought I was just sort of unfit for
science and I never knew why and I'm
sure part of it was just not seeing
people who looked like me in science
we all bring these stereotypes and
prejudices to our decisions about people
and it also means that we can all undo
that
the future of science is so much
brighter and stronger because there are
more women and minorities and people
with lots of different backgrounds but
it could be even stronger